bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct c'est parti pour un nouveau
tour de la cus ports du département en
26 minutes
page spéciale à suivre ce soir sur
l'inauguration du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les premières compétitions sur la piste
aux records ont vu la victoire des
français face aux britanniques
retour sur cette belle soirée il l'a
fait à 102 ans robert marchand a battu
son propre record du monde de l'heure
avec près de 27 kilomètres parcourus sur
la piste du vélodrome ce vendredi en
tennis une nouvelle victoire au tournoi
future de feucherolles pour le belge
maxime authom déjà vainqueur en 2012 le
louviérois s'impose en finale face au
français josselin ouanna évidemment
comme d'habitude en fin d'émission
tous les résultats du week-end mais on
passe tout d'abord à cette page spéciale
vélodrome avec cette belle inauguration
du centre national du cyclisme français
mais en seconde partie d'émission mon
invité qui est déjà présente avec moi
sur le plateau du 7-8 sport virginie
aurensan la capitaine de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles m'a déjà rejoint nous
parlerons avec elle deux de ses
premières 24 heures du sport féminin et
nous verrons un petit peu l'image qu'ont
les saint quentinois et les et les
yvelinois du sport féminin et du basket
féminin plus particulièrement bonsoir à
vous on se retrouve tout à l'heure j'en
parlais dont les titres le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a été inauguré
ce jeudi en grande pompe une soirée
ponctuée par des duel
france/grande-bretagne tant attendu le
nouvel ennemi montrent un françois
pervis a été le premier coureur à
s'imposer sur la piste images de
jonathan vilma le ruban est enfin coupé
par la ministre des sports valérie
fourneyron les compétitions peuvent
démarrer lors de l'inauguration du
vélodrome elles sont évidemment amical
mais elles n'en ont que le nom car un
mois des championnats du monde en
colombie
les coureurs français entendent bien
marquer les esprits britannique
c'est un masque ou gagner tout
simplement des mes collègues et moi on a
vraiment mis 2
bah de tout gagner même si celle ci
logiquement leur médecin un peu moins
d'un mois après leur installation les
tricolores sont déjà la porte du
vélodrome au quotidien dans leur
préparation aux mondiaux à l'équipement
bien on découvre la piste et tout
l'outil qu'on a à disposition pour aller
préparer ces jeux olympiques de rio
et c'est vraiment
toute la soirée les duels se sont
succédé entre nos bleus de france et les
sprinter britannique et carton plein
pour les tricolores qui se sont imposés
sur les six épreuves programmées
karine vitesse individuelle et par
équipe et sous la clameur d'un vélodrome
plein c'est super on n'a vraiment pas
l'habitude surtout enfoncé gérer on a
plutôt l'habitude de faire des courses
mouillart allez les parents qui est qui
nous encouragent donc la voir tout ce
monde et puis
on a deux invités des amis de la famille
et moi l'histoire retiendra que françois
pervis est devenu le premier coureur à
s'imposer sur la piste du vélodrome
nationale reste à confirmer ses
promesses dans un mois à cali cela fait
maintenant près d'un mois que les
équipes de france ont pris leurs
quartiers au sein du centre national du
cyclisme français
il s'entraîne désormais dans une
configuration de course ce qui n'était
pas le cas auparavant à l'insep et leur
victoire écrasante jeudi soir lors de
l'inauguration
face aux coureurs britanniques
montraient hôtels déjà les effets de ce
nouveau vélodrome
j'ai donc posé la question ce jeudi au
champion du monde du kilomètre françois
pervis lors du 7-8 lac tu sais un peu
trop tôt pour le dire mais je pense que
les effets et on va bientôt les voir
puisque les champions du monde en cinq
mois et forcément cette piste là c'est
qu'on avait avant lui faire du bien et
on va très rapidement s'apercevoir est
alors sur les méthodes d'entraînement on
sait qu'à lindsay vous étiez un petit
peu limité à cause de la longueur de la
piste ici c'est une piste aux dimensions
olympiques là vous allez pouvoir
s'entraîner façon course
oui c'est ça c'est pour ça que le la
piste ces deux rondes plats étaient a
été construite on pas enfin pouvoir
optimiser nos bracket course
pascaline os était beaucoup trop court
qu'on était vraiment trop et on
l'arrivée en championnat et à
l'entraînement les semaines avant on
n'avait même pas utilisé notre raquette
de course donc maintenant ça s'est
terminé
c'est une très bonne chose maintenant on
a ce super outil et on va vraiment
pouvoir optimiser nos entraînements est
allé décrocher deux belles médailles aux
championnats du monde et aux jeux
olympiques est ce qu'on vous souhaite et
alors on sait que vous êtes installé
tout près d'ici
nous en profiter pour devenir unis
montrent un veau aux habitués à la vie
saint-quentinoise oui c'est très facile
je habite à un kilomètre de la piste
pas loin du centre commercial donc je
suis
on peut dire qu'il y aura du pétrole ici
c'est super c'est pas surpeuplée
cc c'est beau à voir se voir garder des
beaux bâtiments c'est c'est ce paysage
et c'est du bâtiment assez récent donc
c'est un cadre de vie très agréable
le vélodrome est évidemment à la
disposition de toutes les équipes de
france et quelques jours après les 24
heures du sport féminin leaf
mine moins en verve en ce moment au
niveau des résultats que leurs
homologues masculins espère évidemment
passer un cap en vue des prochains
championnats du monde
c'est notamment le cas de 110 clair que
vous voyez à l'écran qui a terminé
deuxième de l'épreuve de vitesse
individuelle jeudi soir derrière sa
compatriote virginie cueff niveau
d'entraînement on peut faire un peu tout
ce qu'on va dire ici c'est pour les
thermolite et tu vas la longueur de la
piste
donc c'est vrai que c'est bien et on a
commencé mais j'ai quand même hâte de
voir en vrai mon avis tu es au lendemain
de l'inauguration du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à 102 ans
robert marchand a battu son propre
record du monde de l'heure après avoir
parcouru près de 27 km nous avons
évidemment suivi cet exploit au bord de
la piste avec elodie mois les 500
personnes présentes dans les tribunes du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ont du mal à y croire
la grande aiguille de l'horloge n'a pas
encore effectué un tour complet que
robert marchand a déjà amélioré son
propre record de l'heure j'espère faire
ça dans quelques années quoi 102 ses
combats pour faire sa place à son âge il
l'objet de pas d'avoir un régime
alimentaire et sert à rien une hygiène
de vie correcte ça c'est certain ce gel
pourtant une heure auparavant
le cycliste balmanais semblait moins
confiant je parle dans le néant le
diable cette affaire j'aime pas si
l'album off the wall veux pas vous dire
tout ça c'est des bons surtout que j'ai
peur j'ai pas vraiment un monsieur
contre elle est vraiment en conséquence
ans monsieur pas offrir enfin j'ai pas
d' excuses après s'être équipé le
champion part à l'échauffement et
impressionne déjà les plus grands la
vitesse il est bien un allure bon c'est
vrai qu'il n'est pas très aérodynamique
parce qu'il n'arrive pas vraiment à bien
se pencher sur le sur le vélo mais là il
tourne à une à une allure on a
l'impression qu'ils pourraient tourner
pendant deux heures comme ça avant tout
à l'air date on est un petit peu plus
vite à l'échauffement
dès les premiers tours de piste robert
marchand tourner les jambes comme un
cadet applaudi par les supporters venus
de toute la france à chaque passage
c'est la 56e fois que robert marchand
passe derrière moi en 30 minutes sur
cette piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour l'instant il roulait à une allure
moyenne de 26,8 km heure le record du
monde est donc bien parti
le centenaire née le 26 novembre au 10
911 possède selon ses médecins
les capacités cardiaques d'un homme de
50 ans pour ce record
l'union cycliste internationale a créé
spécialement cette catégorie pour lui
après une heure d'effort du haut de son
mètre cinquante et un robert marchand a
réussi son pari
26 km 927 parcouru record pulvérisé
pourtant il aurait pu mieux faire
j'ai dû me voir j'ai été pas avoir en
forme et et par enfant traité seulement
quand on recommence
et quand on lui a demandé s'il pensait
déjà au prochain record
il a répondu qu'il voulait d'abord
continuer à vivre vous le voyez
désormais tous les jours le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines attire tous
les regards et les curiosités ce
week-end environ 12000 personnes ont pu
le découvrir lors de deux journées
portes ouvertes
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images sur le parvis
les files d'attentes sont de plus en
plus longues pendant deux jours le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines a
ouvert ses portes au grand public et un
seul mot vient à la bouche des visiteurs
dirais que c'est très très
impressionnant
toute la voûte qui a reçu avec tous les
espèces de reich est pas ce que c'est
mais c'est une construction qui est très
impressionnante oui à peine entré dans
l'enceinte les curieux aperçoivent la
piste olympique et la plupart s'attarde
à contempler cet outil unique au monde
en tribune
c'est très aéré vraiment je pense qu'on
a un point de vue magnifique sur la
piste et l'arc central n'importe où on
se trouve dans le dans la salle à sion
c'est très très bien belles réalisations
des gradins au centre de la piste il ne
fallait descendre que quelques marches
pour se retrouver exceptionnellement sur
leur central zone habituelle de
l'échauffement des professionnels
l'occasion d'approcher un équipement
spécifique nécessaire pour la piste on
en a un mais pour la route
il ya des freins et iatos à celui-là lé
havre un peu plus léger il ya le minimum
strictes ça doit pas donner ça c'est
très beau a pas envie d'en faire
si cette opération permet de faire
découvrir le centre national du cyclisme
elle pourrait faire naître quelques
vocations la piste est un est une
discipline assez méconnu parce qu'il ya
très peu de vélodrome encore moins de ce
calibre là puisqu'on peut considérer que
le site est vraiment unique
donc voilà c'est forcément quelque chose
qu'il faut démocratiser et puis qu'il
faut expliquer aux gens du territoire
qui sont pas tous des sites histoire ce
week-end douze mille personnes ont pu
découvrir le vélodrome
à l'occasion de la première édition des
24 heures du sport féminin qui a eu lieu
ce samedi virginie aurensan la capitaine
de l'entente le chesnay versailles et
deux passages sur le site huit sports
bonsoir à vous virginie vous allez nous
parler du basket féminin et surtout un
peu de l'image kaka ce basket féminin
dans le monde du sport et s'il ya du
retard au point par rapport aux
homologues masculins mais avant de
parler de cette situation je vous
propose d'écouter ce que pensent et
saint quentinois et quelle image
ils ont du sport féminin en général une
bonne c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour
les femmes en général de conserver une
image féminine bien que pratiquant ce
pas donc c'est d'autant plus méritants
de faire du sport sur toi même niveau
pour une fable que pourra ne voit pas
souvent un bon moi je trouve que c'est
plaisant déjà regarder les matchs de
foot de nos chers française c'est très
bien c'est très bien on est pas encore
elle semble pas encore au niveau des
hommes mais bon je pense que c'est très
bien mais j'aime bien que ça soit en en
patinage ou n'importe je trouve que
c'est très bien une bonne image
je trouve que les nanas se défendent
bien jaj pas une image terrible du sport
en général
sport féminin par contre comme sans
doute ça intéresse beaucoup moins et
sponsors
me semble plus intéressant ce niveau là
pour les saint quentinois c'est clair
les femmes ont presque plus de mérite
que les hommes c'est votre avis virginie
tu mérites je sais pas si on associe le
sport féminin à la double vie ou triple
vie des femmes par rapport à leur vie
personnelle
celles qui sont mères de famille par
exemple plus la vie professionnelle
donc je ne sais pas si on est plus
méritante que d'autres mais fin du mois
on essaye de rivaliser avec les hommes
avec nos moyens
christine kelly la présidente de la
mission sport au csa estime qu'il faudra
des années pour changer les mentalités
dans cette vision entre le sport
masculin et le sport féminin c'est votre
avis n'est encore beaucoup de choses à
faire de ce côté là oui je pense que
d'un point de vue déjà un médiatique on
sait que la plupart des audiences
sportives sont faites pour les hommes
donc si déjà on véhicule un peu moins
l'image de la femme à la télévision les
le public sera peut-être moins de tenter
donc de s'intéresser à ce sport
après d'un point de vue également des
structures des installations - ou même
des moyens financiers on est encore
largement derrière les hommes sur ce que
vous disiez 1 par rapport aux audiences
et aux retransmissions sur l'ensemble
des retransmissions télévisées l'année
dernière en france seulement 7% était
dédiée au sport féminin est souvent sur
des chaînes payantes ça c'est quelque
chose qui doit évidemment changé a par
exemple basket on voit pas beaucoup de
basket féminin sur les chaînes publiques
en tout la gratuite oui on est obligé
d'attendre
par exemple une grande compétition
qu'elles sont finale ou en demi finale
pour pouvoir éventuellement
regardez ce match sur les chaînes les
chaînes publiques
sinon ben il faut passer par d'autres
d'autres chaînes payantes et donc la
plupart des personnes n'ont pas
forcément accès à ces chaînes donc ne
peuvent pas suivre les résultats ou les
compétitions hormis sur la presse la
presse écrite
c'est paradoxal parce que quand on parle
de votre sport le basket féminin il ya
une équipe de france qui marche très
bien avec un bis un titre de vice
championne olympique notamment c'est
c'est quand même assez surprenant ce
gouffre entre bâle et l'it l'équipe de
france et puis le reste du sport en
l'occurrence le basket qui n'est pas du
tout médiatisé
oui effectivement on entend beaucoup
parler de l'équipe de céline dumerc de
l'équipe de france de leurs résultats
dans les grandes compétitions mais à
côté de ça il ya un grand décalage avec
ce qui se passe dans les clubs puisque
actuellement que ça soit en ligue
professionnelle ou dans les niveaux
inférieurs de plus en plus de clubs
dépose les bilans de plus en plus de
clubs légalement sont sanctionnés par
les fédérations
du fait justement du manque de moyens
des déficits des clubs
donc il faut pas croire que le basket
fonctionne aussi bien que qu'on peut le
voir par rapport à l'équipe de france
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de difficulté
chaque année par rapport aux différents
championnats aux différentes poules il
ya des équipes qui déclare forfait donc
de plus en plus de clubs disparaissent
de la carte et du paysage français du
basket et notamment du basket féminin
c'est c'est assez surprenant puisque
c'est quoi c'est un problème de gestion
financière c'est un problème de
dévolution qui se fait trop rapidement
pour ces clubs là dont on pensait à des
clubs de nationale 1 qui ont déposé le
bilan ou des taux même parfois
professionnel de ligue féminine lfb
c'est quoi le problème mais je pense que
les exigences du niveau sont de plus en
plus haute que ce soit par exemple pour
rémunérer les arbitres que ce soit pour
les déplacements l'investissement qu'on
peut mettre également sur des joueuses
puisqu'il faut savoir que lorsqu'on
accède à partir d'un certain niveau
les joueuses sont rémunérés dont il ya
une masse salariale aussi qu'il faut
prendre en compte plus ensuite la survie
du club puisqu'il n'y a pas qu'une seule
équipe dans un club donc c'est toute la
gestion autour qui se fait plus
forcément des difficultés financières
également en termes de sponsors en
termes de partenariats de subventions
également de la part des territoires et
des collectivités territoriales des
municipalités ou bien des conseils
général et c est à cause de ce phénomène
il ya aussi beaucoup de gens qui se
retrouvent sur le carreau comme on dit
ça arrive fréquemment ces dernières
saisons c'est un gros problème ça oui
bah cette année par exemple il ya
énormément de joueuses même des joueuses
de l'équipe de france ancienne joueuse
l'équipe de france qui sont restés
justement sur la touche parce que soit
il demande de trop d'argent soit les
clubs ne sont plus prêts à investir
autant d'argent sur des joueuses au
risque justement d'être en déficit et
peut-être de déposer le bilan
alors c'est pas tout à fait le cas à
versailles on vous rassure à l'entente
de chesnay versailles
c'est un club qui marche très bien
puisque une étude et et récemment paru
vous êtes le deuxième club
parmi tous les clubs français le
deuxième club le plus attractif du pays
avec 637 licenciés ça montre quand même
qu'il y a des régions il ya des clubs
qui attirent encore et peut-être pour
pour longtemps des jeunes et des jeunes
basketteuses en tout cas non oui
effectivement c'est une grande fierté
pour versailles l'entente le
chesnay-versailles d'avoir autant de
licenciés d'être reconnue d'un point de
vue national puisque c'est pas la
première année qui sont à cette place là
donc ça montre bien l'investissement
qu'on peut mettre le club par rapport à
la formation des jeunes par rapport
également à la communication qui peut m
il faut savoir qu'il ya pas uniquement
des équipes qui jouent un haut niveau en
championnat de france soit puisqu'il ya
aussi des équipes loisirs des équipes
débutantes des équipes pour les anciens
joueurs donc vraiment c'est un club
familial qui essaye de proposer le
maximum de deux créneaux pour la plupart
donc des personnes qui sont intéressées
pour pratiquer le basket dans un club
comme vous le vôtre c'est difficile
d'attirer les jeunes joueuses justement
et les demoiselles de 7 8 ans pour les
amener au basket où ça se fait de plus
en plus facilement non je vais dire que
c'est plus facile
à l'heure actuelle notamment via les les
écoles ou les activités périscolaires
à côté de ça cela tranche d'âge la plus
difficile à conserver c'est lorsqu'elle
arriva à la période de l'adolescence au
niveau de 14 15 ans puisque c'est la
période où on sait très bien que les
demoiselles certaines raisons d'autres
préoccupations que le sport donc c'est
plus à ce niveau là que l'écart se
creuse en termes ici de population dans
le club mais après maintenant il ya de
plus en plus et notamment grâce aux
compétitions de l'équipe de france des
jeunes joueuses qui s'inscrivent donc
l'obligation d'ouvrir deux nouvelles
sections d'âge pour pour ces jeunes là
pour revenir plus proprement à l'équipe
dont vous êtes membre qui évolue en
nationale une cette saison après votre
défaite 1 ce week-end à fessia 67 à 59
votre avenir se complique un petit peu
dans cette fête nationale non oui
effectivement on est déjà dans une
position très délicate il nous reste que
six journées avant la fin du championnat
et donc pour pouvoir espérer se
maintenir
on a actuellement avant dernière du
championnat il faudrait dans le meilleur
des cas finir à la 10e place et à la
meilleure 10e place des deux poules pour
espérer à ce qu'on appelle le ranking
être repêché en nationale une donc
notre calendrier n'est pas forcément
favorable puisqu'on va jouer les trois
équipes du haut de tableau
donc on croise les doigts et on espère
que d'ici quelques semaines le résultat
sera plus que positif pour nous je vous
propose de regarder d'ailleurs jeter un
petit coup d'oeil au classement pour
voir un peu votre situation vous en
parliez voilà vous êtes 11e avec 19
points à mondeville 1 derrière à égalité
de points et puis il ya cette dixième
place qu'il faut aller accrocher
c'est encore jouable il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas un fossé entre vous et rennes non
sachant qu'on les reçoit chez nous d'ici
trois semaines
donc on aura l'avantagé du terrain pour
essayer justement de conserver la
victoire qu'on avait pu acquérir au
match aller chez elle
donc on espère que nos supporters bien
évidemment seront là pour nous
encourager pour faire en sorte que ben
on arrive à gagner ce match qui pourrait
être déterminant pour notre maintien
tout d'abord prochain match ce week-end
à domicile également face à wasquehal
donc comme d'habitude j'imagine
j'imagine pardon au gymnase mont boron
non j'ai l'asbl rpr cette fois ci merci
beaucoup en tout cas virginie de passer
sur le 7-8 sport et puis on suivra
évidemment cette fin de saison qui
s'annonce quand même haletante du côté
de l'entente le chesnay versailles
en tennis une nouvelle victoire au
tournoi future de feucherolles pour le
belge maxime authom déjà vainqueur en
2012 le louviérois s'impose en finale
face au français josselin ouanna diminué
il faut le dire par une blessure à la
cuisse
olivier maniscalco et patrick jacques de
dixmude pour le résumé
déjà vainqueur il ya deux ans le belge
maxime authom s'impose une nouvelle fois
au tournoi future de feucherolles opposé
en finale au français josselin ouanna
illustre tombeur de marat safin à roland
garros en 2009
le louviérois remporte la rencontre 7-6
7/5
légèrement blessé ouanna a tenu à
disputer la finale mais a clairement
souffert dans ses déplacements
c'est vrai qu'il avait un peu de mal à
la crise donc j'essaye de le faire
bouger mais frappait tellement fort que
des fois je voulais juste la mettre
dedans et serait pas assez est bon les
coûts qui l'attend et il est il en a mis
beaucoup de temps donc c'est vrai que
c'était pas facile même blessé donc
j'essaie d'être solide et bon à la fin
il a un peu craqué que les derniers jeux
étaient un peu plus facile quoi c'est
vrai qu'on joue c'est toujours pour
gagner même si je sais que les futures
c'est comme les plus petits tournois
jdir atp maintenant il est très bons
joueurs donc c'est jamais facile de les
gagner donc je suis quand même très
content d'avoir gagné aujourd'hui
vainqueur pour la deuxième fois en trois
participations maxime authom gagne 13
places au classement atp pour être
désormais 300 8e joueur mondial
josselin ouanna et lui 271e
dans ces résultats du week-end tout
d'abord place au football ce week-end
était synonyme d'ailleurs deux victoires
pour les club saint quentinois 12e
journée en retard devise division
d'honneur à versailles et versailles a
réalisé une performance de qualité en
s'imposant 3 0 à domicile face à bobigny
avec cette cinquième victoire de la
saison les joueurs de david giguet font
un bond au classement et passe de la 12e
à la cinquième place en promotion
d'honneur match en retard de la 11e
journée trappe s'est imposé 2 buts à 1
face à garges les gonesse en football
féminin on reste dans le sport féminin
évidemment ce week-end au stade de la
couldre montigny le bretonneux lors de
la 13e journée de division de lésigny
montrent elles ont empoché leur seconde
victoire de la saison face à biesheim
sur le score de 2 buts à 1 les joueuses
de jean dany grossesse ne sont plus qu'à
trois points du premier non relégable
gravelines en rugby 15e journée de
fédérale 3 plaisir continue sa série
avec une sixième victoire consécutive
face à boulogne billancourt sur le score
de 25 à 21 du joueur de philibert
profite dans le même temps vous le voyez
de la défaite du troisième protocole bo
pour prendre 12 points d'avance en
basket 16e journée de nationale 3 trappe
s'est incliné à poissy dont le derby 65
à 58 de son côté l'entente le chesnay
versailles s'est imposé sur son parquet
76 à 69 face à l'association laïque
césaire levillain
or le rock est 9e journée de national 2
on suit évidemment les chocs ce
d'elancourt et nouvelle défaite pour les
shops les joueurs de benjamin ferran
recevait le leader vierzon au gymnase
chastagner samedi soir malgré une
première période plutôt correct il faut
le dire les élans courtois s'incline
logiquement 10 buts à quatre et sont
toujours lanterne rouge de leur poule
ils n'ont toujours pas connu la victoire
cette saison et doivent déjà regardé
vers la saison prochaine pour une future
saison en nationale 3 volley-ball 9e
journée de régionale une après sa belle
performance le week-end dernier face à
flairer plaisir villepreux le leader et
bam ontinyent 1 s'est inclinée ce
week-end sur le terrain dernière cruelle
défaite 1 3 sets à 2 avec une cinquième
manche perdue au super tie break 17 15
et vous le voyez plaisir
deux de chute qui s'incline à domicile
face à conflans sur le même score 3 sets
à 2 handball 3e journée de la phase
finale du championnat de france des
moins de 18 ans plaisir à débloquer le
compteur
victoire en s'imposant à domicile face
au paris ga lexip le galaxy club 37 à 33
les plaisirs war remonte à la troisième
place
encore une petite info avant de nous
quitter ce mardi demain à 11 heures le
christian prudhomme dévoilera le
parcours de l'édition 2014 de paris nice
pour la cinquième année consécutive les
yvelines accueille le départ de la
course
rambouillet il recevra notamment la 2e
étape lundi 10 mars et selon nos
informations le peloton ne devrait pas
passer ne devraient pas rouler devant le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
plus d'informations évidemment demain
dans le 7-8 l'actu avec wilfrid richy
avant de nous quitter votre agenda du
week-end de rendez vous à ne pas rater
tout d'abord le bike and run vous en
avez l'habitude à la minière à
guyancourt cette épreuve en duo où se
mêlent course à pied et vtt donc à la
minière à guyancourt départ à 10 heures
ce dimanche 9 février et durera du rugby
aussi ce week-end vous pourrez assister
à deux matches de gala
chez les jeunes les catégorie crabos et
reichel entre le stade français et dijon
au stade du bout des clots de maurepas
coup d'envoi à 14 heures c'est la fin de
cette wii sport merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain même heure même lieu
bonne soirée sur tv fille